the jurogan experience i was out in this
drainage this grizzly bear
this grizzly bear my dad's there
and i'm cow calling okay and you think
the elk's coming i think this elk's
coming but it's not it's not
i see the elk go across this ridge right
it goes across this ridge
and then i see this brown flash go down
this hill in front of me and there's
there's a bit of a you know if you look
like this this this brown flash has to
go down this ridge and then around the
corner of the spine of the bridge and
stay down in the valley i know that
above me is a elk carcass freshly killed
yesterday
so i'm calling i'm waiting for this big
block i'm looking this way
and i turn around
i look down below i mean 100 yards below
me
my dad's here i'm here and i turn around
below me and there's a giant bear
100 yards below me
i turn all the way around like dad
there's a bear there's a bear there's a
bear there's a bear i have my pistol
right here
this is a dash
he's not he's a bow only i have a pistol
and bear spray
his dad have bear spray he does not
at this point he's not
so luckily i'm between him and the bear
the bear goes down the drainage i
remember
as a hunter mostly i'm worried about is
this a black bear or grizzly bear i
didn't know at the time it was kind of
shadowed in this ravine as it was going
up
and
i'm looking through the binders i'm like
i don't know what this is i'm not sure
if it's a black or grizzly bear grizzly
bears have a distinct hump that you're
looking for that's different from a
black bear
and they can be and this black bear is
sauntering down
at the risk of making this a longer
story yeah
explain why it's way more dangerous if
it's a grizzly
a black bear you and i have experienced
this in alberta together
a black bear is not as aggressive not as
predatory black bear attacks are very
less frequent than grizzly bear attacks
i don't know that i could explain kind
of just the nature of a grizzly bear in
a black a black bear is an omnivore in
many ways
a grizzly bear is a carnivore
and in this scenario i would be if it
was a black bear i would be looking to
shoot it rather than being afraid of it
because i love black bear meat it's
delicious and black bear fat you've had
clay nukem on you make bear grease it's
it's one of the best
things that there is
so i i guess that maybe explains the
difference but for for people like
in comparison it's like a golden
retriever versus a wolf
pretty much that's a pretty good
comparison it's a completely different
animal i wish there was a wall apologies
to kind of really lay it out there but
you could probably say german shepherd
wolf yeah something that's probably
that's a [ __ ] i'm trying to be like
more comedic right this
yeah it's a different animal it is and
and i would say that
you seen it in when we were hunting bait
in alberta yeah when a black bear comes
in
you're willing to stand your ground
you know we were on our way we saw
grizzly yeah in alberta when we were on
our way to where we were hunting
eye to eye with the grizzly is wild it's
a wild thing and when
when a grizzly bear comes through a
standard timber or you know mountainside
in this case things go quiet and we
didn't even when i was in alberta the
one i've seen in the wild was not that
big but the one you saw was big this is
one of the biggest bears i've ever seen
i'm talking big hind end just
i don't give me a give me a roundabout i
have no
idea i would guess it at the six and a
half to seven feet
oh i don't know how to guess that how
much it weighed
this is 350. no [ __ ] way more than
that 450. 700.
we later found 700 pounds we later found
the track on the road
we later found the track on the road
where we walk in every morning
to the drainage this little two tractor
road where we walk in we found this
thing's track
so it is sauntering up
this drainage
and there's a moment
where my mind's not in the right spot
it's in this in the place of is this a
grizzly bear a black bear
and uh now that i look back on that
moment it that bear was about two
seconds away from ripping my face off oh
my god
i'm cow calling
to that bear i'm a
cow elk
and to me i wasn't scared i wasn't
pulling for my pistol i was watching it
as a hunter might watch any game species
that it comes with that thinking an
elk's gonna come over the rich yeah
how much how many pounds maybe seven
eight hundred pounds i don't know i hope
i'm not speeding that's a big one let's
be nice and say 600.
imagine a 600 pound super predator one
swat
one
full clip towards you i've interviewed
many people that have had their face
ripped off their testicles ripped off
i know the
the pure carnage that a grizzly bear
like that can do and i also know
in my pack is a tourniquet and all the
medical supplies the man might carry but
i also and i'm pretty close to town my
dad's there we have our cell phone
service we're not in the back country i
know at this point when i determine it
to be a grizzly bear it's already
walking up the drainage away from me i
determined it's a grizzly bear i know
then
that if it turns back to us we got a
problem but if it keeps going up the
drainage i know where it's headed said
is it at el circus that was there
and so luckily for us it
it goes up the drainage
it
heads over towards the elk carcass and
ducks into the timber and that's
i mean it's not the end of it but that's
the end of that encounter and you're
carrying a pistol i have a pistol what
caliber 44 magnum
taurus 44 magnum ultralight and i have a
chest holster that's from a guy named
that's razko a guy in bozeman makes his
chest holder that attaches to the bottom
so is this a revolver it's a revolver
and and i have bear spray on the hip
uh belt of mine so you can get off six
six shots and get off six shots six
shots
and i know
again having been in the industry and
talked to a lot of people that have had
encounters i know kind of how this is
going to go
and likely how it goes
is the the only way you get out of it is
um you get mauled and the bear loses
interest or the person that's with you
saves you in some manner right yeah
um there's a pretty famous dad doesn't
have a gun he doesn't he's a bow and
you're in front i'm in front oh so i'm
between these two and again this is is
your pistol in
is it do you have to open up a snap to
pull it out or is it it's fully
identical it's fully in a molded
holster that i can pull out present
right easy it'll be double action
because i don't have it cocked and do
you have a thought when that's happening
where he might run away but if i shoot
him he might attack me
yeah i mean it's like a calculation
right yeah and again as a hunter i'm i'm
more interested in what is this thing
doing why is it here than i am like i
should run away right and that is um i
think both appropriate and also far
probably not the best thing to be doing
man
like it should probably be
can you remember what you thought like
what went through your head when you
realized it wasn't an elk
and it was a giant grizzly bear
finally
finally yeah because you
are in the country where you know
dude i've been out in june setting a
trail camera and heard a wolf howl
i i i told you i talked to the game
warden he's like there's bears around
and so
the thing that you do is you prepare for
the worst and you really really prepare
for the worst
and i and i did it knowing that there's
folks that i've talked to like i said
that have had had really life-changing
experiences
one of them in kodiak a brown bear
ripped off his testicles one of them in
alaska
uh
a brown bear or i think grizzly bear
ripped off his face
and so i know these stories i know them
all too [ __ ] well there's a video
that one guy yeah pretty recently glenn
bond yeah how many are four or five
years ago
right
that would have been uh back and yeah
roughly
or whatever it would take a few years
yeah that one is available online it's
it's horrendous kind of yeah they keep
pulling it offline they put his face
back together again pretty good
i have the full
i talked to that guy i know that guy
very well and i have the full story of
that you can listen to it on the hunting
collective there's a there's a podcast
with brett i listened to it
it's amazing
it's a whole nother
show probably but
it's like that's one of those
conversations where like a vegan or an
animal rights activist would be like
good
good some people might say that some
people might say that like i don't know
i'm glad that [ __ ] and people said
that about that about brett bond and his
father glenn yeah
there was a lot of people saying like
because they were hunting bears at the
time and they were hunting bears in
their den on the denali highway in
alaska
yeah
and so people were like good you hunt
them in their den that's what happens
and again
and that's where where i come back to
the emotion of finally
because so much of my hunting life in
montana has been anticipation of
those encounters
and that was the first ever
with a bear with grizzly bear yeah well
not the first ever of my life first ever
montaigne i i was once on a caribou hunt
up in northwest territories
uh they helicopter you out into the
middle of nowhere and then you have a i
think a 12 hour delay before you can
hunt once you've been helicoptered into
the wilderness i think it's 12 or 24
hours but you have a delay before you
can hunt so you literally have to sit
there and wait
and we were there at a time in august
when there was no
darkness it was literally light pretty
much the entire 24-hour day
and so we sat on a ridgeline
and we were glassing for caribou in the
in the period where we couldn't hunt
and here comes this
sow grizzly bear down this drainage
every
bush that she went by [ __ ]
every
piece of moss
crush she was upset
she's having a bad day whether her cub
got
taken or she was just in a predatory
mood it was i remember glassing her with
a spotting skip going like hope she
doesn't come over here and we were
sitting on kind of a is that normal
behavior when like a club gets eaten by
a boar
i don't know if that's normal behavior i
imagine it to be for folks who don't
know that that happens a lot and the
females try to fight the bore off i
imagine it to be i imagine them to be
aggressive in the times that they need
to be but i don't i don't know
enough to know if that's like every time
a cub gets eaten she goes out and whacks
the [ __ ] out of the next thing she sees
i don't i don't know that but in this
case this sal was alone
she was not uh she didn't look all that
mature but she was going down this drain
it's just everything she saw she was
hitting and i thought well if she comes
by me
you're [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] yeah and we
were kind of on a what we would call it
a glass and tit which is kind of a
raised up ridge
and glass and she got at some point
below us where we couldn't see her what
a terrifying idea of a mad grizzly like
a road raging grizzly
you're like dude oh
and then you think that it is it's like
someone just [ __ ] [ __ ] you and where
did grizzlies live right the grizzlies
don't live by the urgent care right
right they live in places where if they
whack you you're [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
unless your friend knows how to break
both your legs yeah you have to crawl to
safety right so you can so in an example
of brett bond who we were just talking
about his he saved his father his father
got his face ripped off by grizzly bear
he comes running down the hill with his
454
shoots this bear bang bang bang bang
bang kills it it actually
i was reading some of the his accounts
of the hunt
he measured five and a half feet from
his bootstrap to where the bear died
when he was defending his father's life
his father had been attacked god how
much did the bear weigh
the bear is now in uh glenn bond who's
70 he's probably in his 80s now
is in his living room
he got it mounted full standing mount
and it's in his living room i bet that
bear weighed 800 plus pounds
and again apologies for getting that
wrong if that's the case but we got to
wrap this up but before we wrap this up
yeah how does that bear story end is
that it
yeah the bear uh leaves and goes to eat
that elf carcass how close were you at
the closest time 80 yards
toward death how many seconds would it
take for a bear sprint at you from 80
yards two
do you think you'd have time to pull the
gun well we did a whole thing with clay
newcombe if you look on the old meteor
youtube where we tried to figure out how
quickly you could draw your bear spray
pistol not so quick nice and quickly
uh i probably would have gotten mauled
um
but again that's the reality of the
world in which we live
joseph that's a nice thing to say if you
don't get mauled
if you do get mauled you should say i
should take a roller skating yeah if you
don't get mulled you're like ah
if you don't get like i am going roller
skating from here on out i'm gonna take
up crochet like if you got mauled and
you had the opportunity to not get
mauled you're like yeah i'm gonna do
something else i'm gonna keep my face